now health secretary good morning to you
apologies about the the the connection
problems i mean it's just saying in the
introduction to you there that
the big problem is we want clarity on a
lot of these big questions the problem
is we just
don't have a lot of answers i mean
you're in a position now surely where
you've got to say to a lot of these
questions
i just don't know at the moment well
that's been
the case throughout the pandemic i mean
we've been learning about the
virus all along haven't we i'm one of
the
critical questions for instance right
now is
after you've been vaccinated how much
impact does that have on
you on how much you might transmit the
virus as well as
the impact on you in terms of uh serious
disease and that's one of the key
questions
that will impact on how quickly we can
we can lift measures um and we
we would like to have more information
on the
new variants that we've seen abroad
uh especially uh the the two particular
variants of concerning
that have emanated from south africa and
brazil
and we're working on those but we find
out more all the time
but in terms of those variants we'll go
into a bit more detail on all of those
uh in a few minutes but on the
the uk variant if we can call it that it
means
it's been said this week that perhaps it
is
more deadly than the original variant
that we've seen in the uk i mean how
worried should we be about that
well we should be worried enough all of
us
about this pandemic to follow the rules
and it is just so important that people
do you know this morning i've
come out of my formal self-isolation i
haven't actually left the house yet
because i haven't needed to so even
though i don't you know i've got pinged
by the app last week
that requirement to self-isolate and not
leave home
at all that ended at midnight last night
um but i didn't need to come into the
studio this morning because we can do it
by
by modern technology and so i haven't so
we must all follow the rules and stay at
home
because you know whether the um
whatever the the exact nature of the
uk new variant and the scientists do
think that it may be more deadly and
they've got various estimates on that
from about 10 more deadly
to to a bit more than that we are not
exactly
certain about how much more deadly but
in a way
for all of us that doesn't matter what
matters is we've got to get this virus
under control the only way you do that
is by stopping the social contact
and following the rules but we need
clarity don't we on all of this and part
of the problem is
the messaging i mean you you've heard
that leveled at you you're throughout
the course of this pandemic
but you know we we were told this was a
more deadly strain and then the chief
scientific advisor said patrick valens
comes out and says well
the evidence at this stage is not strong
so we're left wondering what to believe
no i don't think that's the case for the
vast majority of the public actually
communicating risk is challenging and
it's challenging for media outlets as
well i understand that
but when we put the scientific evidence
out there for instance
one of the studies says that this might
be 10
to 50 percent more deadly um
there are there are uncertainties in
that that's the nature of science and
and the thing i find heartening is the
vast majority of the public
understand that and that can lead to
stray headlines you know
because um because the science is
uncertain
but what really matters is what people
need to do
and that of course is to stay at home
now
so therefore we say that there is a risk
that the new variant
is more deadly we know that it is more
contagious more transmissible all of
that means
it is even more important that people
stay
at home and i think it's very important
that everybody
listens to the uh to the scientists
who who of course explain the nuances in
what we do know
and what we don't know and communicating
risk and uncertainty is one of the
hardest things to communicate
but i think it's incumbent on all of us
and it's a responsibility of others
politicians
of the scientists themselves of course
and of the media
to explain that there are uncertainties
here but there are some things that
are clear including the rules
that we all need to unfortunately live
our lives by in order to keep people
safe
yeah so we are in a situation where this
the new variant
is we know quite a lot more
transmissible
at least the potential of it being more
deadly and yet
the the lockdown restrictions we have
this time round are looser than what we
saw
last summer does that need to be looked
at does there need to be a tightening of
restrictions
well there is early evidence that this
the lockdown
is uh starting to bring uh cases
down uh but we're a long long
long way uh from that
from being low enough because the case
rate was incredibly high
and you can see the pressure on the nhs
you can see it every day
you know these the the nhs are doing an
amazing job in incredibly difficult
circumstances
and so we i am confident in the
measures that we've got in place now
what really matters is that everybody
follows them
and the reason for that is not just
the the the death toll each day which is
far
too high but also because the pressure
on the nhs
from including from people who
thankfully you know come out of hospital
alive you know
the pressure on the nhs is enormous
and that has knock on consequences for
all for people with you know who suffer
from all other illnesses
uh so it is very very important that we
continue to follow the rules that's a
that's at the core of it uh even whilst
uh we um you know whilst we whilst we do
everything we can to support the nhs
through this
where are we though in terms of
compliance then you talk about the rules
and sticking to the rules but there is
concern about compliance i mean the home
secretary
said this last week that you know it's
only a small minority of people who were
flouting the rules and yet it's your
team that's come up with this idea of
paying people 500 pounds
to isolate when they test positive a
scheme that costs
very nearly half a billion pounds a week
now if you're spending that sort of
money
it has to imply doesn't it that you are
really concerned that compliance just
isn't good enough
well we do we want to absolutely ensure
that everybody
can and does comply especially with the
self-isolation when you are either a
contact
or you have the disease yourself those
are
the most important parts of all of the
rules that we've got
in place you know the fact that when i
was pinned by the app last week i went
home and i stayed home and didn't leave
my
front door for the for the whole of the
rest of the week
you know because it's about breaking the
chains of transmission
when we find somebody who's positive it
is absolutely critical
to stop them from infecting anybody else
and it's so easy we know for this
disease to pass on
and that means we do need to encourage
people to come forward
to get tested because testing is now
very very widely available over half a
million
tests a day and and also at the other
end
you know what if you are either somebody
who's tested positive or you're a
contact
we need you to stay at home
totally and isolate entirely um
and these two parts of the
of the test and trace system that
actually the machine of the test and
trace system is now
working really well over 90 of contacts
are reached which is
excellent work the challenge is making
sure that enough people come
forward for testing and that when people
are do need to isolate then they
absolutely do
and so um we so of course we're working
on how we can strengthen that system
now the the policy that you mentioned uh
is not
uh government policy and as you can
imagine all the time we look at these
things
but the purpose is to ensure that the
most important bit of all of the
isolation rules which is the
self-isolation either if you're positive
or if your contact
that those work as effectively as
possible because it's breaking the
change of transmission
that is how we actually get this down
i mean it's understandable that you know
a universal 500 pound payment has
sort of garnered an awful lot of
headlines the pm said on friday there
are there are no
such plans at the moment for such a
payment i mean
is it is that as a scheme written off
now
well look we of course throughout this
pandemic we've looked at all
options including options that in normal
times would be extraordinary
that isn't the government policy but
there is a lot of work going on
to work out how with local councils
uh we can make this work as effectively
as possible
and it's about reaching all you know um
it was it was financially
straightforward for me to
uh to self-isolate because i'm uh i'm a
salary
cabinet minister um but if you're
self-employed that could be much harder
so
of course we always look at this now
there is at the moment
uh 500 pounds available for those on low
incomes
and that is in place for for for this
purpose
but obviously we keep well we keep all
policies around covert under review
because coming back to our opening
discussion we're always learning more
about the disease
um look there's you mentioned that the
different variants and there is real
concern about the brazilian variant and
the south african variant
that's raised questions about whether
borders do need to be tightened up i
mean
in your view should there now be a
blanket ban
on people coming into this country and
quarantined and or
should we still be looking at sort of
high-risk versus low-risk countries
we can't risk the progress that we've
made and
the discussion on borders has changed
for two reasons
first is because the vaccine rollout
here
is going so well over five million
people have been vaccinated as of this
morning
three quarters of all over 80s in the uk
have been vaccinated
which is absolutely brilliant progress
similar number
of care homes around three quarters and
in fact we've vaccinated more people in
just the last three days
than france for instance has in the
entire uh in the entire history of this
disease
so the vaccination program is going very
well and at the same
time there are new variants that you
mentioned particularly in south africa
and brazil there's two that we're
we're particularly concerned about that
might have
a lower response to the vaccine now we
don't know the degree of that we've been
really clear
that is something we don't know but we
are looking into
both at portland down and also in south
africa we actually have a trial in the
field to see how well
the oxford vaccine works in uh in south
africa
and we're working closely with our
counterparts there but
in the meantime we've got to have a
precautionary principle
that says let's not bring these new
variants
back to the uk and further than that
the new variant i really worry about is
the one that is out there that hasn't
been spotted
because you know brazil and south africa
like us
have a decent size genomic sequencing
program and this these genomic sequences
are important because there's
how you spot the new variant now we do
about half of all the genomic sequencing
in the world it's one of the reasons why
we could pick up the new variant uh that
was first discovered in kent
but there are there's probably others
elsewhere that simply haven't been
picked up
because the country doesn't have that
genomic sequencing service
now i want to see our capability
actually made available
across the world so that others if they
see a sharp spike like we saw in kent
uh can can send their samples and we can
find out if it's a new variant
in the meantime forgive me forgive me
for interrupting a lot of people will
will appreciate that position but
they'll say right as we're spotting
these new variants what i wasn't clear
from what you were saying is
do you think then at this stage with the
variants emerging
that we should have an absolute blanket
ban on people coming into this country
yes that's just what i was coming on to
um in the meantime whilst we do all of
this
scientific work internationally and
whilst we roll out the vaccine program
so successfully
here at home we've got to have a
precautionary principle so
we've introduced pre-departure testing
and we've also
introduced checks on everybody to check
that that has happened and the passenger
locator form is
is completed but it is absolutely vital
that we protect this country from a
new variant that may not be as
well dealt with by the vaccine
we cannot risk the progress that we've
made
you talk about the importance of the
vaccine and five million plus doses
given out
at the moment and yes that that i mean
it's a great milestone and i know
people that i know have had the vaccine
are delighted that they've had it but
they're
very very real concerns now about this
policy of delaying the second dose
to 12 weeks where it was three to four
weeks
i mean the scientists themselves are
saying look
we just don't know what impact that will
have
on the efficacy of the vaccine when
you're looking at the double dose with
that sort of gap
in between well what we do know is that
this policy
is going to save lives and the reason we
know that is because
so long as there is decent efficacy
after the first dose
and we know we have a we have a high
degree of confidence that that's the
case
then in a situation where there's only a
limited supply
because we're able to deliver this and
inject this at the rate at which it is
being
manufactured you know and the nhs is
getting it out as quickly as it comes in
and in that situation you want to get as
many people to have as much protection
as possible as quickly as possible
so the way i put it is this if you have
two grandparents
uh who are in their 70s or 80s
and you want and you have two doses of
vaccine
you obviously would want each of them to
have one dose
when you know that one dose is effective
rather than one to have
the two the full to those schedule and
then the other to have no protection
at all and so that's the reason that
we've made this
uh this decision and it is
it is essentially because this is the
way to save
most lives fastest and that's so you can
totally understand why that's the
approach that we've taken
there's so much to cram into this so i
i'll have to leave that one for now can
we just have a quick look at
i mean there's a few issues around
schools and if we can stick with a
vaccine idea for now there's i mean a
big report in the
mail on sunday i think it is this
morning looking at a lot of head
teachers getting together
really wanting to push forward a plan to
have
mass vaccinations in the february half
term get
all education workers vaccinated
within that half term period now i don't
know how the logistics of that would
work but is that a scheme you would
willingly look at
well it's a it's not really a matter of
the logistics the logistics i'm sure
could be
organized and the nhs is sorting the
logistics of the vaccine rollout
uh brilliantly and the the challenge
is the supply vaccine so supply is the
rate limiting factor
and the nhs is then able to get that out
and delivered
right across the whole uk as fast as it
comes in
and the question is who should have each
dose as it comes in who should have each
marginal dose
and we've taken the decision quite
rightly to
go through in order of clinical need
starting with those who are most likely
to die from this disease in care homes
the over 80s
now able to vaccinate the over 70s and
those who are clinically extremely
vulnerable
but forgive me for interrupting people i
mean people are aware of that but you
also talked about
breaking the chains of transmission and
schools
are clearly a a key place when it comes
to transmission particularly
with the new variant where we know
children are more vulnerable to picking
it up
uh well we we do obviously
obviously we also want to break the
chains of transmission uh but
we've got but the first thing we've got
to do is stop people dying uh from the
disease if they catch it
and so this has been looked into in
great depth and i see that you've got
the deputy chair of the joint committee
on vaccinations and immunizations on
later we're going through the clinically
those who are clinically vulnerable
four groups by the 15th of february and
then through the rest of those who are
clinically vulnerable
and after that there's a perfectly
reasonable debate to be had about
what who should go in what to order next
where teachers have got a good shout
uh to be very high on that list and
those discussions uh
are are going on of course they are and
i think that it's a very valuable debate
but a bit like the
um the 12-week dosing schedule you'll
understand why we're taking the approach
that saving
lives is the most important thing
and we're therefore doing this
in clinical priority in order to save
the most lives
forgive me we're getting really pushed
for time on this next question can i ask
you for a simple yes no or don't know a
school's going to return at easter
well i would i would hope so but we but
we've got to look at
the data we've got to look at the impact
of the vaccination program
so that's that's a don't know you just
don't know at this stage
well we make these announcements as soon
as we know if we knew for sure then
of course we'd uh we would let everybody
know the education secretary said that
it will ensure that schools have two
weeks notice of return and
you know i don't know whether it'll be
before then uh or then or
we've got to watch the data as we all do
20 minutes is never long enough with
your health secretary i just want to
squeeze every second out there's this
big report about the state of the union
in the sunday times this morning um if
the snp do really well in the elections
in may and we're saying you know more
than 50 percent of people want to see a
referendum
in the next five years i mean they've
got a mandate to call a wildcat
referendum haven't they
well you've heard what the prime
minister's said about that what i'd say
is that the this pandemic
actually has taught us just how how much
stronger we are when we all
work together because the undoubtedly
the most effective part of this
pandemic has been the vaccine program
which has been a
uk program working very closely with all
the devolved
authorities so you know it's uk science
and the uk
science budget that helped to discover
the vaccine and
and we bought on a uk basis so we're
able to buy early that's why i was so
far ahead of the rest of europe
and then it's delivered through the
local nhs's so
this is this is exactly how
a demonstration of how this country
works so much better when we work
together
and you know it would it would pay me to
see a separation
and i work very closely with the health
ministers
in the three devolved nations
and we just clearly work so much better
together as a country
and i hope i i i i think that's the
right way forward and
and it's you know i love this i love
this i love my country and every part of
it
and i think when we work together we
work very very effectively
secretary of state good to talk to you
this morning thank you